mais je suis plus polis porte-parole
excuses avant nous est donc porte parole
de l'union régionale des professionnels
de santé messieurs merci d'être avec
nous en direct mathieu de vlaeminck vous
attendez quoi aujourd'hui de la
mobilisation puisque on le rappelle la
loi sanitaire a été en partie invalidée
par le conseil constitutionnel
pour l'instant on a donc peu de choses
la mobilisation malheureusement parce
que on reste quand même dans le cas
d'une mobilisation qui en dynamique
particulière et demi qui sont pas celles
des jeunes on avait quand même des
revendications sociales assez marqué
mais où on a finalement une sorte de
dougga où on est à la fois contre eux
contre le vaccin contre de passer à
table
évidemment les obligations restent assez
dit qu on pense pas que ça fera sans la
médiation qui pourra poser jaune car
adam ce jour du cadre
parce que globalement nous a lui-même on
n'a pas la mobilisation wu qui est clair
c'est qu'on ne manifestera avec des
personnes qui sont ouvertement raciste
tels que certains savoirs et certaine
aux hommes et femmes politiques qui sont
devant en ligne sur ces manifestations
la donc globalement nous attend que ce
sont des personnes comme ça qui mène aux
obligations noonan a tenté peu de choses
finalement et c'est bien dommage parce
que se passer ni tard c'est quand même
une atteinte énormes animaux qui donc on
a vu une mobilisation quand même on a vu
il ya des gens de plusieurs bords qui a
des envies signer des gens non vaccinés
jean pierre tarn à nyon est ce que vous
comprenez le message aujourd'hui que
veulent faire passer les français ils
étaient environ 200 milles samedi
dernier non j'ai du mal parce que le
comité tentera de nouveau de flamber
dans notre pays
si vous regardez les courbes ça n'avait
atteint le point le plus bas fin juin
début juillet il ya eu malheureusement
je pense une erreur colossale de
communication début juillet en enlevant
l'obligation ou du moins l'intérêt
d'avoir le masque si vous voulez dans
l'espace public et ça n'a pas raté s'ils
voulaient le comider tard frentzen et on
est à des taux d'incidence de plus de
mille dans les départements d'outre-mer
ce toute la ceinture méditerranéenne on
est largement autour des 600 je rappelle
qu'on était quasiment étale hier
sanitaire lorsqu'on a dépassé 200 l'an
dernier et en est quand même
actuellement obligés de l'agencé
régionale de santé d'occitanie commence
à envisager des transferts de patients
en réanimation c'est à dire que le
système est en train de craquer on est
au plus mauvais moment
on a tous les soignants qui sont enfin
en vacances après un an et demi sur le
pont on nous applaudissaient maintenant
me crache dessus et il n'y a plus la
ressource
on va dire humaines pour absorber on va
dire la preuve
lavin qui nous arrive en partie lié à
l'apprenti sorcier si vous voulez ça
c'est dramatique
mathieu blin manque finalement vous
regrettez que tout nuit sociale et
professionnelle fois contrainte par le
fait d'être vaccin oui mais je pense que
le plus grave et c'est là le point
central à mon avis de se passer c'est
que on va pouvoir se faire contrôler par
le tout venant
je pense que la question elle se résume
pas en des termes de liberté contre
sécurité parce que le principe de tout
passé d'être sous une certaine forme
liberticide d'atteindre liberté mais
globalement je suis assez peu pour la
liberté de transmettre le quiz à
quelqu'un d'autre
c'est une liberté dont je veux plus de
vaccins c'est la solution face à ça
toutefois je suis contre le fait d'aller
au barça le cinéma d'aller au musée et
de me faire contrôler par quelqu'un qui
est finalement pas qui n'est pas salarié
c'est quand même assez dingue que l'état
a demandé l'ex avoir deux gars estime à
tous les citoyens ont valu dans ce défi
totalement différente et ça c'est quand
même très inquiétant parce que oui on va
vers de plus en plus de sécuritaire
d'autoritarisme et c'est ça en fait ce
que représente véritablement cette fois
sécurité globale stop une société de
surveillance et une société qui sortent
des cadres de l'état de droite
considèrent aujourd'hui jean pierre pin
damiens et 1 passe 1 et ares 1 pour
freiner la propagation du virus on vous
l'avait dit le taux d'incidence est très
important ce moment mais le conseil
constitutionnel a censuré la disposition
portant sur les éléments obligatoires
n'est pourtant pas on nous martèle
depuis le début des pistes et traçaient
est isolé oui mais si vous voulez la
france et on veut dire un peu
schizophrène vous est arrivé par exemple
en israël vous arrivez aux états en
grande bretagne vous êtes je dis bien
cueilli à vos descentes d'aéroport on
vous emmène au menu
intervilles un hôtel que vous payez et
vous avez automatiquement un contrôle le
soir de l'arrivée le lendemain dans
l'après midi
vous avez fait étal comme d'autres
journalistes on va dire des contrôles
qui sont assez stricts en grande
bretagne
bien qu'en france où vous faites un
confinement on va dire light qui n'est
pas respectée souvent et où quand vous
décrétez qu'il faut isoler même le
conseil constitutionnel trouve ça normal
mais je suis navré si vous pensez
sincèrement que la civilité des gens en
france et de ne pas sortir alors qu'ils
ont recueilli 600 franchement malade oui
mais si son revirement auquel ils en ont
tellement marque
bon effectivement il sort et ils en
mettent deux partout sur le pass
sanitaires je crois qu'il faut haletant
des décrets d'application qui devrait
sortir probablement demain soir mais moi
j'ai un problème en tant que médecin si
vous voulez c'est il ya eu quand même
rappelle al par l'ordre national des
médecins qui dit qu'on peut pas quand
même privé les gens d'un accès au soin
autant je suis effectivement partisans
de stopper les possibilités de
contamination dans tout ce qui n'est pas
on va dire santé parce que quelque part
au final c'est nous qui trinquons en
tant que citoyen mais sur la santé vous
devez maintenir la capacité des gens
alors peut-être pas sur le droit de
visite c'est vrai que la première vague
de contaminations seul d'abord été dans
les hôpitaux ça c'est typiquement
français
mais toi l'hôpital rien pour la médecine
de ville et on a fermé les cabinets mais
maintenant où on a besoin d'eux on a des
retards de diagnostic des retards de
soins importants on s'est quand même pas
p3 confinement il est important que les
gens puissent aller soigner ça m'embête
que par exemple dans les établissements
de santé le patient qui se pointe
comment voulez-vous décrétée par
quelqu'un qui effectivement en était de
couleur le dis c'est pas les la
puissance publique
c'est un souvent une société de
sauvetage comment cette personne met en
capacité de juger que la personne vient
elle n'est pas en dehors du national
d'urgence annoncé par un c'est pas
acceptable
il faut qu'on puisse accéder librement
aux structures de soins qu'elles sont en
cabinet qu'elle soit en établissement
par contre il faut effectivement
verrouiller le reste parce que la
situation devient tendue
trois régions métropolitaines sont déjà
avec un plan blanc active esther
condamné à rappeler les soignants y
compris à l'étranger
on va les gens huit jours d'altrad
d'acculer
mathieu 2 la main vous êtes président de
l'ue nerfs quel sera le protocole
sanitaire qui va être mis en place dès
septembre au mois de juin dans les
lycées mais alors qu'un triple
information
on n'a pas vraiment l'impression que ça
va être bis repetita avec puisqu'on eu
l'année dernière après restreint la
région léa simple c'est que l'on n'a pas
de moindres éducation nationale pour
mettre en garde et au togo c'est la
stricte
comment on veut mettre en place des
classes nous on n'est pas plus de quinze
ou vingt avec une suppression de poste
de police à terme à 1800 pour cette
année bon ça va continuer cette année le
guen sont quand même assez inquiétant
donc non pour l'instant on n'a aucune
information sur place sur le contrôle de
leurs terres pour l'année prochaine et
nous les professeurs les parents
d'élèves
on est très inquiet parce qu'on a envie
de retourner au lycée et que la
contamination lost se sent chaîne dans
les lycées que les listes et
redeviennent des posteurs conçoit privés
d'éducation et s'élance un pâtre le
risque c'est qu'on a encore l'impression
une fois d'être dans le titanic en rade
de foncer droit devant l'iceberg et
aussi à jean michel blanquer ne compass
et la stabilité
on sait très bien que l'iceberg baas et
les prendre en pleine face et encore une
fois c'est une catastrophe une
catastrophe à la fois ça y est qu à
patras pédagogique et c'est ça qu'on
veut éviter donc on demande à jean
michel blanquer
oui pour baugé dépasse de professeurs
oui il faut des protocoles stricts ne
peut pas se baser uniquement sur la
responsabilité individuelle pour exemple
que olivier ça se passe bien jean pierre
tarn et tarn amiens ont fait 1 qu'il ya
certains français qui doutent de
l'efficacité de l'utilité du vaccin anti
qu'ovide pourquoi autant de défiance
parce que on est des gaulois parce que
la france est toujours du mal on va dire
à accepter ce que paris décide
je pense que si vous voulez il ya
peut-être un défaut d'information
et puis il ya un climat ont vaillamment
politique à un an de la présidentielle
qui fait avec les gens ce christ sur les
deux extrémités du spectre
mais bon vous pouvez pas être allez vous
inscrire dans une école de procès de
santé si on n'avait pas la vaccination
contre l'hépatite b
on a heureusement vu disparaître à la
poliomyélite en france quoi qu'on ait
encore moi j'ai vu récemment une
patiente qui avait quand même 35 ans
seulement 1,6 citoyenne française
métropolitaine elle était passée à
travers le spectre de la vaccination je
vous dis pas le calvaire que cette femme
vit et puis vous pouvez pas aller en
guyane si vous n'avez pas votre cas
fièvre jaune
donc c'est un peu irrationnel il y a une
grosse part de récupération politique
qu'il a à mon avis strictement rien à
faire c'est quand même un problème de
santé
et c'est un problème on va dire de
liberté par un look seulement de celle
que tant qu'on aura pas on va dire une
vaccination à 98%
ben on aura toujours ces résurgences
d'épidémie est l'exemple et caricatural
entre le 1er et le 7 juillet la courbe
devient exponentielle et yen alors elles
fléchi ces cas derniers jours tout la
corde mais par contre sur les animations
sa double toutes les semaines et là je
ne sais pas comment on va faire
les problèmes et perspectives qui avait
annoncé c'était début septembre
mi-septembre balco vide a réussi à
déjouer tous les tours il arrive au
quasiment mi août un mois d'avant ce
sergent ternat mion merci d'avoir été
avec moi je rappelle que vous êtes porte
nom que vous êtes un porte parole de
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé est avec vous et bien voilà on va
faire plus simple vous êtes et lieu de
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé
et puis avec vous un autre invité un
c'était mathieu de vlaeminck président
de l'union
nationale lycéenne merci à vous de
monsieur